devront en payer le prix.
Élyse Allard.ommencé à stocker
beaucoup de livres en réserve en
prévision de...
- L'entrepôt de cette librairie
de MonC'est que les libraires ft
des réserves.
PHILIPPE SARRASIN, propriétaire
Librairie de Verdun
on stocke toujours beaucoup.
On stocke encore
cette année, parce qu'on a été
prévenu que c'était fort
possibnt tomber manquant plus
vite que d'habitude.
comprendre cette pénurie,
il faut remonter avant
la pandémie. Le livre étant
ont ajusté leur production.
SERGE LOUBIER, président
Marquis Imprimeur
Ils ont changé la vocation de
certains moulins pour en f
du papier d'emballage. Tout
s'envoie par colis maintenant,
alors ça prend d
- Mais pendant le confinem
les gens se sont remis à lire.
Le nombre de livres vendus
au Québec a grim 2020 et 2021.-à
la mode, ce qui fait que
la demande a augmenté et que
l'offre a baissé, en même temps.
Tempête parfaite.
ANDRÉ GAUVIN, PDG
erie Gauvin
- J'ai lu des rapports qui
parlent de pénurie de livres
Des tablettes vides.
- Mêe, la compétition
entre imprimeurs canadiens etam.
- La pâte de a à d'autres
endroits présentement.
qui imprimaient en Asie, se sont
aussi butés à l'explosi
du prix du transport
par conteneurs.taire
Librairie de Verdun
d'Asie,
ça passe par Vancouver, pis là,
cet été, on avait aussi
Il y a des titres qui sont
arrivés beaucoupetardetardetardd
parce que les trains passaient
plus à cause des feux.
maisons d'édition font
des pieds et des mains pour
s'ajuster à la demande.
commerciale Éditions Écosociété
- On doit prendrsions
très en amont, avec de très gros
tirages, donc des gros risques,
- Des dépenses supplémentaires
qui feront grimper le prix
des livres.
rie de Verdun
- On achète plus cher, on vend
plus cher. La facture, elle va
être refilée ultimement
au consommateur.périence dpériee
domaine, j'ai jamais vécu, puisn
père, non plus ont jamais
vécu ça.- Une situation inéditee
bien d'autres durant
cette pandémie.
Ici Elyse Allard,
Radio